got on the elevator in LA one day and
the lady said oh I just saw you in the
hudsucker reduction I had a long haul
from where I came from to here but here
we are your job as an actress to give it
your best shot each every time so that
was a period there in the early 80s when
I didn't get any work because I would
ask these questions he's an American
actor producer and narrator he is known
for his distinctive ly smooth and deep
voice he's ranked as the third highest
box-office star with over 4.3 billion
dollars in box office gross he's Morgan
Freeman and here is my take on his top
ten rules for success to collect
unemployment you have to go out and hunt
for employment they give you have a code
and mine was as a clerk typist so you go
out you look for work as a clerk typist
in one day I just I can't keep being
forced to be a clerk typist so I went to
the employment office and I asked to see
the supervisor and I was led into this
office miss pretty little native redhead
whose name was mrs. Lipton what can I do
for you and I said you're forcing me to
be something I'm not
I have to go out and look for work as a
clerk typist I'm not a clerk typist I'm
an actor so I just can't keep doing it
this way it took this thing and stamped
my employment book said you get six
months go be an actor
[Music]
so if mrs. Lipton is alive today mrs.
Lipton I'm an actor the box-office
success when the Shawshank Redemption
came out with Dumb and Dumber which
snuck my love
well no but that you know just the
juxtaposition of box office and and
what's that other term critical
Shawshank got really good reviews but
because nobody could say Shawshank
Redemption
it didn't get word-of-mouth and I don't
care how much you promote a film if you
don't have word-of-mouth emai promoting
it people have to be able now if we go
and say listen I saw this really
terrific film it was called shank Sam
Shimshon got on the elevator in LA
one day and later said oh I just saw you
in the hudsucker reduction
so that was the reason it was not a
box-office success no word of mouth at
all here's a stat from from your show
and it's just the richest 85 people on
this planet have as much money as the
poorest 3.5 billion yeah right at on the
planet however no sex it's not far off -
in America no it isn't far off in
America but we still didn't we still
here don't abandon the idea that it
isn't finite it isn't finite if you were
born where were you born me yeah Baton
Rouge Louisiana batteries General
Hospital there you go Louisiana I was
born in Memphis Tennessee
I had a long haul from where I came from
to here but here we are right so proof
is in the proof of the pudding is in
eating and here we sit at the dining
table but it's hard to when you say that
to some people because they say oh there
you go with a pull yourself up by the
bootstraps thing and you know you're
just being respectable not everybody can
do that
look everybody can everybod it doesn't
courage courage is the key to life
itself a lot of people who are born in
situation of a survive just I'll never
get out of this so they won't I say to
people say well I would like to have
done so and so and so so you could have
done it so but I couldn't get out of
here man the bus runs every day you're
exactly right now you exist if they're
if they're if you can conceive it in
your mind if you can think of it you can
do that's a human condition if we can
imagine if we can do it right and I
think that the condition of each
individually human your job as an
actress to give it your best shot
each every time so yes I'm going into it
with the idea that I'll play it to the
best of
my ability and they wouldn't give it to
me the road they didn't think I was
capable of pulling it off oh I wouldn't
take it if I didn't think I was capable
of pulling it off so what advice would
you give purely in an acting sense to
yourself 30 40 years ago same advice I
gave myself 30 40 years old
go get a job
Act there are unfortunately those of us
who say well I'm going to be a star
that's way out there in the ether
somewhere I won't be a working actor you
can pull that off so act work work I
someone asked me once and you're about
to do it what would you do if you
weren't an act if you didn't make it as
an actor what would you do I have no
idea I would act somewhere maybe I'd be
driving a cab maybe I'm working
somebody's yard whatever I'm doing I'm
going to belong to somebody's little
theater group
I will act because I'll die if I don't I
got into the air force because I was it
as it turns out I was romanticizing that
whole idea you know we were refighting
World War two as I was growing up so we
had all these heroic movies and I fell
in love with the idea of flying and then
when I got into the Air Force
I had just big eye-opener that racism
was rampant there also and that I didn't
I not qualified or suited is better word
for a military life that kind of
unquestioning obedience to a lot of
things that I think of stupid didn't
quite go over well yeah yeah so when I
got out I was I was an early discharge
it was almost dishonorable
you know because I just really didn't
fit but the catalyst actually was I did
get to sit in a jet trainer because I
had a lot of people behind me to get me
into flight school and stuff but sitting
there it occurred to me that this is
absolutely not what I want it's it isn't
movies it's for real these no no this
little red button on a joystick controls
guns with real bullets and I'm sick I
said that for quite a while and knew
that if I made a strafing run and needed
a camera here and I needed the people to
be able to get up and go back to number
one so I got out of that plane on the
runway at North Island Air Station a
Naval Air Station and I walked away from
that and towards acting I knew that it
was all about the movies it was all
about the movies I got on stage the very
first time when I was eight years old I
was brilliant
then I got on stage again four years
later when I was 12
brilliant again so by the time I was 13
it was pretty much a foregone conclusion
and everybody else's mine teachers
parents that acting was going to be my
thing
I hadn't like made a conscious decision
I'm going to be an act I don't think you
do I think you just that's what you do
the first stage play I did in New York I
was working with Stacy Keach and vivica
lenses that was a great experience for
me you talk about a master class you
have it there okay Stace it come out of
Yale University I think and I was much
more advanced as a stage actor than I
was but Wow did I have big ears and was
I ready to learn so you just sit and
watch it's always a learning experience
ah the big thing I learned from working
with Pearl Bailey was professionalism
she was total professional total total
total professional she always gave 100
percent 110 percent and performance and
I watched her very carefully it was one
of those performers that you say this is
the way to go this is the way to be in
this business beyond time know what
you're doing do it fall out give all you
can and son
that's a lesson well as I said I went to
the movies all the time which I've seen
the movies and at some point it struck
me rather dramatically how much I wasn't
in the movies not the way I needed to be
in the movies and if you look at a lot
of the disaster movies in that period
the only people left on the planet well
wait so now my thing is if I get in the
movies I want to make sure that I speak
about that then if I'm able to do it I
want to talk about it so there was a
period there in the early 80s when I
didn't get any work because I would ask
these questions I auditioned I don't
think I even got to audition I
interviewed for the movie the thing the
remake so I read the script and I go
back for the audition and the producer
or the director one Rose said did you
read the script I said yes what do you
think I said well you've got 11 people
at the South Pole 8 of the scientists
and then you have a cook a mechanic and
something else
they're all black none of the scientists
are what do you think I think needlessly
said and get that job again though you
know Providence rears our beautiful head
when glory came about I was just floored
because I knew about the 54th
Massachusetts regiment from a 1-page
thing on this day in history and Jet
magazine has talked about this sergeant
water the Medal of Honor for his
activists at this charge with this
outfit so the history is there is there
to draw upon but we ask ourselves we
mean black people why why aren't we why
don't we figure more in it I need
something that's going to engage me that
makes me sit up and think I refuse to
take part in anything that is going to
denigrate people
especially me five here we go
yeah water like that space I like I
shouldn't be doing this
helium it's helium organ it is helium is
very undignified no your voice sounds
great it's not undignified some people
just have voices like this so you're
actually making fun of those people
I want to thank you so much for being on
the show and please would you ever like
to come back I'm never coming back thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because JP Annette asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I also love to know what you
learned most of Morgan Freeman which of
the ten clips had the biggest impact to
you and why what change you're going to
make in your business or life as a
result of watching this video what's the
impact leaving the comments below and I
will join in the discussion finally want
to give a quick shout-out to Chris
Shane's from happy worker calm Chris
thank you so much for picking up my book
it really means a lot to me those you
watching if you want to change that a
shadow in the future video make sure to
grab the book and also email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon